ai ragazzi vi ricordo sempre di fare
stretching di fare allungamento a fine
allenamento perché è fondamentale
importantissimo preveniamo gli infortuni
recuperiamo prima e soprattutto viviamo
meglio li evitiamo anche di avere
fastidiosi dolori il giorno dopo
ricordiamo anche che tutto il giorno noi
siamo sotto una gravità di 9.81 e ci
schiaccia costantemente a terra ma noi
in quanto crostatine restiamo sempre in
piedi anche non allenandoci la gravità
ci schiaccia sempre costantemente
teniamo sempre a mente la nostra schiena
e quella che soffre di più una schiena
mobile è una schiena giovane ti faccio
un esempio guarda prova a chiamarmi che
sono un giovane chiamami ho la schiena
bloccata
dimmi marco che vuol dire che è vecchio
e giovane che ama mi adesso sono un
vecchio se io sarei un vecchio siamo noi
che decidiamo di essere giovani se anche
voi non volete essere soggetti alla
gravità se anche voi volete dire a
quanti anni
fate e frecce non si direbbe forche sono
mobile perché sono vecchio
quindi vado a terra partiamo subito
dalla schiena la prima parte da che
sente il carico maggiore della giornata
gravità cambio sbatte il microfono no
importante l'ho comprato io rido sotto
al baffo
apro guardate questo vecchio e per quei
vecchi e presente quelli di maestri
lupia cambio quadricipite bene spingo
bel respiro cambio e vado sono un
vecchio chi può dire che io sia un
vecchio sono giovani sono io che decido
la metà ria cambio pingo una gamba giu
l'altro la porto a me rilasso la mia
schiena la mia zona lombare e riprendo
vita riprende energia l'universo non mi
schiaccia cambio benissimo siamo sempre
questo allungamento cambio tutte e due
via o le bel respiro su tutto fuori
l'aria arrivo arrivo piano piano
arriverò sempre più lontano non mi
faccio schiacciare non tengo ma la testa
bassa sempre bello elegante
se io salt e ho la testa bassa non
c'entra un cazzo continuato a fare
stretching immaginate che io faccia un
salto così
tutto il peso dell'universo mi schiaccia
verso terra guardate lo stesso salto
prendete la testa vedete come la gravità
non può nulla
guardate che so fare guardate dicevamo
tutto il peso dell'universo non può
nulla cambi posizione della crostatina e
scalava la montagna questa è la
crostatina sulla cascata della montagna
cambio altra parte fondamentale da
tenere giovane il tendine d'achille
finché il tendine d'achille giovane
spingo porto su non c'è trucco non c'è
inganno devo sempre mantenerlo giovane
cambio spingo e adesso lo lascio giu
vado a spinge non si capisce un cazzo
con questa cosa in testa spingo qui
sento la zona lombare sento vado giù
dove posso savoia gaga per respiro
se avete la chioma funziona ancora
meglio non c'è trucco non c'è inganno
guardate il mio tendine come giovane
come fresco mano sul ginocchio a
protezione asato jajaja tengo sul
tendine tiro su lascio spingo e vado
sentite questa zona dovrà lombare come
si stira effetti della gravità come non
può nulla come fossi un astronauta è
asato jajaja insomma aver fatto questo
apro tutte e due le gambe
aspettate aspettare scusate non lo
mutate questo pezzo sennò capiscono che
non sono un vecchio ecco qui passato ha
fatto e mi spingo più avanti che posso
chi riesce aperto terra sentito la
gravità finge ma guardate
importantissimo tenere sempre la nostra
muscolatura flessibile come un arbusto
il vento che cosa fa un arbus tutto ciò
che si muove che mobili in natura non si
spezza mai il vento guardate che fa
questo albero tutto ciò che ridge è
spezzato sempre plasmarsi passatore
cambio ok da qui spingo con questo
ginocchio verso questa spalla per resto
composto con punto bel respiro miele vo
sempre verso l'alto non state mai così
lo stretching non è mai passivo sono
elegante sono qui sento il gluteo che
spira da qui il cambio dopo una botta
fino sotto stretto il gluteo continuo
ecco il ritorno su spingo sguardo verso
l'infinito peccato che le inquadrature
asta dall'altro lato e non può vederlo
guardate nello sguardo spingo bene col
braccio vicino al gluteo in torsione la
schiena la colonna e cambio tutto
dall'altra parte che palle tutta
un'altra parte va bene come se aveste
fatto ok spingo bene dritto abbiamo
quasi fatto lo stretching l'allungamento
in realtà è un fattore di respirazione
prendo aria buttò fuori si avvicinò a me
è fatto latore e vado ancora schiena
gambe per le braccia sticazzi non ho
fatto niente per le braccia ok cambio
questo non fate così se la gravità mi
porta giù come faccio a stare così giù
quando mi sento così che sguardo verso
l'infinito non sono le mura che mi
fermano benissimo cambio faccio una
capovolta per chi riesce così di
eleganza
e vado spingo un po caviglia indietro
tra tra tra trackball e la mania terra
appunto i piedi cane a testa in giù dal
canottaggio dal cane a testa in giù
cento e valore sapienza tiro bene
l'addome
da qui ri punto i piedi via ca ne vado
giù mi metto in questa posizione dello
yoga si chiama posizione dei venti in
pace con l'universo non vittima della
gravità piego mi stendo miz rotolo bene
con la schiena
chiamami da vecchio ei come potresti
dire che sono vecchio è il signore
benissimo ragazzi se volete lasciare un
pò il collo collo troppo sto facendo una
caduta di svezia
possiamo fare anche da terra rake zen 2
3 e 4
la prorompente tutto dopo aver fatto
questo stretching potete tornare le
vostre vite incantevoli con un'altra
forma con un'altra postura